[Música]
[Aplausos]
alguien escuchado aquí sobre el síndrome
de guillain barré
algunas personas es un síndrome
extrañísimo que le da a una de cada
100.000 personas
nadie conoce las causas y yo siempre ha
dicho que es como sacarse la lotería al
revés por aquello de las estadísticas te
da a través de un virus o una bacteria
en mi caso hepatitis tipo a y tu sistema
inmunológico cuando quiere atacar esta
enfermedad empieza a atacar a ti y se
come la mielina de los nervios dejando
pelón el nervio y el músculo algo que es
sumamente doloroso tu sistema nervioso
central deja de mandar órdenes al
sistema periférico y en ese momento
estás desconectada y eso quiere decir
que te puedes quedar parcial o
totalmente paralizado
hace ya varios años yo salí de mi
burbuja totalmente enamorada ilusionada
para irme a vivir a alemania con el que
ahora es el papá de mis hijas estaba
verdaderamente ilusionada por la
decisión que había tomado pero era una
decisión bastante fuerte yo estaba
dejando un buen trabajo a mi familia y a
mis amigos para enfocarme a conocer una
nueva cultura un nuevo idioma estaba
verdaderamente muy contenta mi decisión
nunca pensé que a los seis días de
llegar a alemania me iba a encontrar así
de un día para otro dejé de mover
piernas brazos tronco cara hasta que
tuvieron que llevarme a terapia
intensiva sin saber qué es lo que me
estaba pasando
cuando llegue a terapia intensiva los
doctores decidieron
en tu bar me ponerme un tubo en la
garganta hacerme una traqueotomía porque
en mi sistema respiratorio se estaba
atrofiando
en estos momentos yo no podía mi
parálisis facial era tan grande que yo
no podía hablar no podía mirar tampoco y
en esos momentos yo le hice entender al
doctor y porque me di cuenta de que el
único órgano que me servía al 100% en
esos momentos y no estaba paralizado era
mi cerebro y sabía que si me conectaba
en un tubo se iba a desconectar mi único
órgano así es que de muchas formas
intenté decirles que por favor no me
conectarán eso traía varias
consecuencias durante dos noches no
dormí en conciencia con mi respiración
porque si tenía una bocanada de aire o
un ronquido podía morir los doctores no
iban a llegar a abrirme y hacerme una
traqueotomía
estuve 10 días en terapia intensiva
salvando mi vida mi sistema inmunológico
mi sistema respiratorio mi sistema
digestivo y mi sistema circulatorio
todos estaba atrofiando en esos momentos
lo único que estaba en mi conciencia y
en el cerebro era vivir no quería morir
tenía una vida por delante estaba muy
enamorada y yo había ido a alemania con
esta intención de ser feliz pero la vida
de repente también te saca de tu burbuja
cuando salí de terapia intensiva después
de 10 días las noticias no eran
esperanzadoras me dijeron que no iba a
volver a caminar quizá en 7 u 8 años
para que se pudiese construir mi sistema
periférico de nuevo que la cara tal vez
no la iba a volver a mover porque no me
pudieron dar cortisona por la hepatitis
entonces los nervios de la cara son
mucho sostenía totalmente paralizados
y bueno así fue de alguna forma mis
pensamientos se conectaban a emociones
desastrosas tenía enojo frustración
coraje incertidumbre pero sobre todo
mucho miedo porque esas emociones se
conectaban en mis pensamientos inicial
este hombre se va a buscar una mujer más
sana vas a regresar a méxico no tienes
trabajo y seguramente dependerá de tus
padres y además iba a dejar de hacer lo
que más me gusta en la vida que es
bailar
así es que al segundo día que llegué a
neurología recuerdo muy bien que lo
único que tenía frente a mí eran mis
dedos de los pies
y de alguna u otra forma yo empecé a
darle órdenes al dedo gordo me enfoqué
en el dedo gordo y empezó a decirle
muévete muévete muévete claro que no se
movió ni en un día ni en dos ni en tres
quizá pasaron ocho o diez días cuando yo
vi como milimétricamente mi dedo gordo
se movía en estos momentos que vi que mi
dedo gordo se movía y que podía mover el
índice el anular el medio al mexi que
mis tobillos en ese momento vinieron
pensamientos de muchísimas cosas y mis
emociones cambiaron y llamé a los
doctores venga megan a ver imagínense
doctores en alemania- hospital y ellos
vieron como movía un poquito mi dedo
gordo y dijeron ya le dijimos que la
señorita no se va a volver a mover quizá
en siete u ocho años esos son los
reflejos
y origen y esos no fueron los reflejos
ya nadie me quitaba de la mente eso y
menos cuando cerraban los ojos y yo me
veía así
[Música]
me veía bailando y después de que me vi
bailando me veía vistiendo me me veía
arreglando me veía trabajando me veía en
mi vida normal y estas conexiones me
traían emociones de felicidad de
esperanza y así empecé a mover sin
querer los dedos todos mis dedos hasta
que me pudieran poner en una silla de
ruedas y yo arrastraba mis pies con las
sillas de ruedas los doctores no
entendían pero así gracias a eso ya que
me pude parar me llevaron a clínica de
rehabilitación un mes y medio después
cuando llegue a la clínica de
rehabilitación a la semana no los días
más felices de mi vida me casé una boda
muy extraña me casé sentada y con temas
gráficos y la verdad que luego nos de mi
historia y dice oye pues te casaste un
poquito triste no te ves un poco
desilusionada el día más feliz de mi
vida mi cara tardó mucho más en moverse
pero hice exactamente el mismo ejercicio
tomé un espejo me mire en el espejo y
empecé sonríe sonríe sonríe sonríe y
funcionó porque también me visualicé
sonriendo a la vida y a muchas cosas
maravillosas que había tenido ese día
que me casé fue el día más feliz en mi
vida porque ese día no sólo dejé la
silla de ruedas sino baile habían pasado
tres meses y medio de que yo había
salido de terapia intensiva cuando los
autores pronosticaron 88 años salí dos
meses después de la clínica de
rehabilitación y las cosas siguieron
cambiando cuatro años después de haber
salido de la clínica de rehabilitación
nació mi primera hija y luego mi segunda
hija
mis dos hijas porque también habían
dicho que tal vez no me podía embarazar
y a partir de eso y pasaron varios años
me di cuenta que si me saqué la lotería
que a través de lo que me sucedió me di
cuenta de que mis pensamientos no se
iban no iban a ser controlados por las
circunstancias ni los problemas a partir
de ahí mi vida cambió y a partir de de
sant pasado cosas extraordinarias como
esta
y bueno yo solamente quiero terminar
haciéndoles una pregunta en donde estas
están tus pensamientos ahora porque
dónde están tus pensamientos está tu
vida en el futuro
[Aplausos]